CLINT: Oh shoot, where your lips at?
*laughing*
Whoa!
Guys, I don't know if you know;
maybe some of you know, but most of you probably don't...
*slurp*
I love drawing. I... loooove drawing.
I loved drawing since I was like three years old,
and off and on I've been, like, practicing,
you know what I'm sayin'?
As a kid, I always love, like,
how to draw tanks, how to draw airplanes,
and how to draw wrestlers, and how to draw all the good stuff, right?
Over time I was trying to figure out different ways to draw.
You can use watercolor, you can use pencil, you can use a pen -
and you can do it in all these different styles,
and I came across this one style -
it's like a contour drawing,
where you can't pick up your pen from what you're drawing,
AND it's blind.
You can't look at what you're drawing.
You have 30 seconds to draw your best friend's face.
Alright, who do ya wanna start with?
NICK: Let's go up and see Sam.
CLINT: Okay.
NICK: Hey Sayyum!
SAM: 'Suuup?
SAM: Here lemme give you, like, a little nice - easy, classic portrait.
CLINT: Yeah, that's perfect.
It's like the pano - the squish pano, right?
You have the randomness of, like, I dunno what I'm gonna get,
but you might get some gold.
Alright, you ready?
Here we go!
Once you do that, you elevate it, right?
You take it to the next level,
And you shade it, like you shade it really well.
And it looks... and it just looks beautiful.
NICK: *laughs*
CLINT: Schweet.
SAM: Whooaa!
There's some crazy stuff in here.
This is Brett-son.
There's another son right here.
There's Cliff again.
SAM: What do you do to practice drawing? Wow, that was sweet.
Do it, do it, do it, do it, do it?
CLINT: Yeah. Inktober is a thing where you, like,
draw something in ink every single day,
That helped a lot, actually, 'cause like,
at first I was like, super careful about what I did,
and then over the course of the month, I kind of developed a style,
like a sketchy style, like, this is kind of
the style - like, what came of this style.
It's kind of sketchy and not really precise,
because with a pen, you just wanna kinda like -
just go with it, you know?
JAKE: What're you guys doin'?
CLINT: This is Sam.
JAKE: *chuckles* That's actually - that's actually -
It resembles him!
I like the rule that you can't remove the pen from the paper.
That really, I think, gives it a whole new level of -
CLINT: It's the bonus challenge.
JAKE: Yeah.
We should go around, we should draw everyone,
and then freaking frame them, dude, just frame 'em up!
Imma grab a pen, and I'm just gonna - just draw everyone.
30 seconds, can't look at it, can't pick up my pen -
Let's try it!
*laughing*
Dude, this one - this one's the best one!
JAKE: I've never had my portrait drawn before.
CLINT: You're about to be horribly disappointed!
*both laughing*
CLINT: Oh shoot, where your lips at?
Maybe that's where they are...
You kinda have to start - yeah, in the center,
'cause then you know, like, where you're at,
and kinda go from there.
NIKO: It's like a perfect photograph! *chuckles*
*muffled laughter*
CLINT: That one! That one, dude!
JAKE: That is a freakin' masterpiece!
WREN: 'Kay, you guys are reacting...
*laughter* Whooaa!
JAKE: These are starting to become incredible.
NICK: You're not allowed to see it.
WREN: I know, I know.
CHRISTIAN: I want to see mine.
(Oh no...)
CLINT: Dude, that's like, some straight-up Planet of the Apes!
ADRIAN: Oh yeah, I can see the resemblance.
Alright, here we go...
WREN: I don't know anything about this soda,
other than what Adrian's told me about it.
And I'm really intrigued. I like sour things,
but this sounds like it might be too intense.
Yeah, so ever since Adrian broke his collar bone, he's been unable to drive.
Since we live within a couple of miles from each other,
I've just been driving him to work every day.
Which is not a problem, but he, you know, has wanted to show his appreciation,
by giving me the world's most sour soda, apparently.
JAKE: I have no idea what that means.
WREN: Sour soda!
ADRIAN: I thought you would like how the bottle looked,
I mean, I thought the bottle looked pretty badass.
WREN: Wait, wasn't this Niko's?
ADRIAN: No that's mine.
WREN: Excuse me?!
*laughter*
Excuse me?! That was almost too easy!
ADRIAN: That is cruel, Wren! That is cruel.
JAKE: Dude...
ADRIAN: ...do one arm, I guess, I dunno.
JAKE: Wait -
We need to get - we need to get somebody else's opinion on this.
NIKO: What's the rule?
JAKE: The rule is, if you're in the game, you're in the game.
NIKO: And if he leaves, it exponentially goes up.
JAKE: Yeah, and if he doesn't do them right now,
for the full extent of his injury...
NIKO: Well you could always pull a Jake and just never fulfill his debt.
JAKE: Hey hey hey hey hey - alright maybe I shouldn't have asked you.
NIKO: Can you do a one-handed push-up?
ADRIAN: ... yeah.
ADRIAN: Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait - **** that.
Wait, I did a hundred push-ups like a month ago.
["$100 for 100 Push Up Challenge"]
*cheering*
CARMICHAEL: Adrian, you won yourself a Game of Life credit!
ADRIAN: I got ONE credit!
ADRIAN: ... right? That counts as a credit!
That counts as a credit, right?
Hell yeah, I'm turning in my credit! I got a broken clavicle!
Wanted to do 10 push-ups (!)
WREN: But now I guess the question is, like,
*should* you have to spend the credit?
(dude) (absolutely!)
ADRIAN: This is WHY you do the hundred push-ups!
For times like this!
NIKO: See, everybody? Long-term investments pay off!
*laughing*
WREN: What?!
CLINT: Shading - We got this janky outline,
and I'm gonna try and make it look 3D.
and try to render it, almost, right?
Essentially anything that's white is coming towards the camera,
anything that's black is going away from camera,
and I'll probably just choose a general light source.
I'll just start.
Imma just do, like, the lightest values first,
and I'm gonna shade everything at a very light value
as a test to see: is this where I want my lighting to come from?
I'm gonna use this - paper towel -
to smudge it and smear it so it's like super smooth,
and it looks just like baby smooth, you know what I mean?
They sell little rolls of paper,
specifically for this
It looks like a pencil but it's made of paper.
I got, like, a general shadow on this thing,
and I'm gonna start making the values
darker and darker and darker and darker...
So that's the first one - it's about 5 minutes.
NICK: Niiice.
ADRIAN: Hey Wren, are you gonna drink that drink?
I wanna see you chug it, for - for doing that to me!
He better chug it.
WREN: I loved Warheads, back when I was in 4th grade.
Oh my god, it's literally black!
ADRIAN: Oh yeah.
WREN: It smells like - *coughing*
It smells like regular Coke, but then after like a moment,
it hit my lungs, and then, like, seized it up.
*coughing*
GABE: Oh yeah.
I used to eat Warheads so much that it would make my tongue bleed.
And I'd still eat more.
WREN: Dude, get that - the raw tongue?
GABE: Yeah.
JAKE: Just drink the soda, man!
Stop stallin'.
WREN: I just wanna try it!
JAKE: Just drink the soda.
WREN: Okay, a little bit more...
JAKE: I mean, not like stop Stal- Stalin has already been stopped,
I mean, like, stop *stalling*.
[johnyboz] *laughing*
WREN: Alright, I'm gonna try it.
(It's not that bad)
WREN: It's not even sour.
ADRIAN: Yeah, that's what I thought.
But it's not like - yeah look at Wren - it's drinkable still...
NICK: Is it worse than coin juice?
["Drinking 2000 year-old Coin Juice"] Whooaa! Augghh!
*sputtering*
NICK: Ewwwww!
WREN: Nothing's worse than coin juice, man...
JAKE: Alright, well that was interesting. Thanks for sharin'.
WREN: This was supposed to be a much cooler segment.
NICK: Chug chug chug...!
WREN: No man.
CLINT: Time to reveal the final shots here.
Some of these turned out,
looking like really funny versions of all y'all,
and some of these turned out looking like real ugly versions of you guys,
and some just turned out not looking like you guys.
Alright here we go - Sam, that's you!
*chuckling*
SAM: Dude that's art!
CHRISTIAN: Oh my god!
SAM: It's like Picasso.
NIKO: I can recognize that.
If you squint - and stand really far away...
NIKO: Those eyes - [unint.] Sam's eyes -
Oh that's Jake!
*laughing*
(Yeah I see it!)
SAM: That makes sense!
It kinda looks like Luigi a little bit.
Yeah I can see Jake for sure.
I like those lips.
Yeah, those freakin' - BAM!
SAM: *popping noise*
- Gabe.
What?! That's not Gabe!
NIKO: That's so obviously not Gabe.
CLINT: That's Niko!
SAM: This looks like that - like, the Beatles' Yellow Submarine style-like art.
CLINT: This is my favorite one. Christian -
*laughing*
CHRISTIAN: Dude, that's totally me!
That's my favorite one.
Those big eyes -
And the hat!
WREN: Dude, that hat -
Oh my god, that looks so good!
That's Nick.
*laughter*
WREN: Oh whoa!
NIKO: - lookin' like Picasso over here.
CLINT: I'm a fan of this one...
*laughing, exclaiming*
WREN: What?!
SAM: His whole face just slid off.
CARMICHAEL: He's like - he's like, "Ehhhh!"
CLINT: - detached, completely from his body, and his face just like - *grunting sounds*
That's Carmichael.
The biggest lips!
CARMICHAEL: Those ape lips - that ape upper lip.
all: Gabe -
(oh wow!)
That's a pretty good Gabe!
(pretty good Gabe!) (it gets better!)
And that's Adrian.
*laughing*
Looks like Markiplier.
So we're gonna put all these pictures on our Corridor Digital Instagram,
@corridordigital on Instagram - go take a look!
Tell us which one is your favorite,
tell us which one is your least favorite and most scary.
Let us know if we should use these as our profile pictures -
maybe on the new banner for the Corridor Crew channel.
NICK: Dude - Doby Day!
NIKO: Yeah dude, Doby Day.
When is Doby Day?
NICK: I dunno!
CARMICHAEL: When IS Doby Day?
NIKO: When IS Doby Day?
CARMICHAEL: When IS D-Day?
Doby Day is the day that Adrian broke his collarbone.
On Doby Day, you have the, umm,
annual... uhh, pickling, in the morning
for your winter stores - yeah, pickling, where you make pickles,
and - you pickle different things,
Followed up by badminton.
Followed up by - we all just drink water for lunch.
Then we all update Creative Cloud. We make them jump to new software versions...
*laughing*
Then, it's ended with, a rousing game of world Olympic hackysack.
CARMICHAEL: And, you have to unplug the Internet.
E-fast?
(E-fast.)
NIKO: Oh, and we all have to get one thing unplugged from our computer,
and we don't know what it is, and we have to figure out how to fix it.
*laughing*
That's real Doby Day!
NICK: I have to hold the camera.
Mmm!
*sucking noises*
CHRISTIAN: I always feel sour right here.
Real hard.
NICK: What's wrong with your face?
CHRISTIAN: That's the logo of the Warheads! Literally the Warhead logo.